في البدايه في القرن بدايه القرن العشرين
هي كانت الدول المصيطره هو الوحيده
والوحيده على صناعه البترول ليس داخل
امريكا عالميه طبعا قبل اكتشاف البترول في
العراق وفي في باكو ويدري بيجان وقبل
احتجاجه في ايران حتى بعد الاكتشافات تلك
امريكا هي الدوله الرئيسيه موسيطره الان
لا زالت امريكا اكبر دوله مستهلكه في
العالم مستهلكه اكبر دوله
تصدر البترول
يعني دوله مهمه يضاف الى ذلك بان شركاتها
منتشره في جميع انحاء العالم ولا اقصد فقط
الشركات البترول لا شركات الخدمات
البتروليه كالحفر غيره وشركات الاستثمار
والبنوك جميعها تدخل في هذه المنظومه وهي
امريكيه والسوق السوق السوق التي لا يتحدث
عنها كثيرا للناس اللي يسوق همم السوق
المستقبليه للبترول
تباع وتشترك في نيويورك لندن في الدرجه
الاولى وبدرجه الاقل
ولو هذه السوق مهمه جدا في تكوين الاسعار
اكثر من اي شيء اخر